how are you you look fantastic oh thank
you very much you look very nice so good
to see you again nice to see you again
um we i did the single guy a little shot
on the single guy a while ago and that's
how we knew each other blah blah blah
blah blah blah
yeah we're old friends yeah we go way
back and you know what i didn't realize
is of course i mentioned in the intro
joy luck club and er and all those
things but i didn't know you also
are in a video game is that right based
on um a pretty popular movie called uh
street fighter street fighter with
uh oh jean-claude van damme no but the
way to really say it is jean-claude van
damme
that's you know it's like a legal thing
right and uh so you're in but don't call
him
jean-claude he likes to be called jc
really yes you know for those who
want to know that i'm not afraid of him
i'll call him whatever i want
and if he's here i'd say that to his
face
i'm so glad he's not uh now
yeah so so this was a movie you did with
him first of all what was he like what's
jean-claude van damme like well when we
did the movie i mean all of us had to
get really fit so i was in the best
shape of my life i mean i was buffed i
was training and really feeling good
about my body but it didn't matter
because as soon as you got on the set
all that mattered was his butt
was i mean every shot involved
jean-claude's butt his butt he likes to
he's proud of his butt yeah and i was
quite jealous of the fact you know
because i thought my butt was looking
pretty rock hard and you know right but
it didn't matter so he actually has
cameras positioned at butt level right
they're actually called butt cameras and
they're there and they're yeah it was a
new experience for me you know
incredible i've worked in front of
cameras before but yes that's very true
and now you're in a video game where
where this is actually you and you're
beating people up using uh karate or
kickboxing or something yes okay can we
we actually have a clip of this which is
very exciting this is the actual video
game starring ming na when can we take a
look at this thing
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
what what the hell was that thing you
were doing after you won what is that
um it's part of the character it has no
no involvement it was contractual can
you do that what is that it is that's a
victory victory dance yes okay so you
can actually probably get out your
aggressions
this way right yeah i'm so proud of uh
this conversation you know from joyla
club er to this this all right well
let's that's what this show does it
brings out the best in people
um now let's talk about let's talk about
er you were on er yes for a while and
and i was curious about that because it
was such a juggernaut it still is such a
juggernaut but it's such an explosion
yeah i try to i get paid 50 extra if i
can work the word juggernaut into the
show
um but anyway uh so on this show i was
curious what's the audition like for a
show like that i mean at the time was
the show already going at the time or
were you in the ground i mean it was
incredible to be you know
able to audition for this part um but
what was really weird was that
the scene that they wanted me to
audition with was was sort of
interesting
it was deb having to perform a rectal
exam
there is a theme to this whole night i
swear
i'm stopping this show
we're turning around and we're going
back home to your grandmother's all
right from butt to rectal to wait so so
your big audition is you're going to do
a rectal exam yes i had to do a rectal
exam and i really really wanted to you
know get this job so
you know being an actor i'm
being very serious i'm like what can i
do to make them want to cast me in this
role
so um i said i'll bring like text gloves
oh that'll like really make it authentic
yeah but make it feel like you know i'm
really that's intern students so i
surprised them with my latex gloves and
um and i asked a casting director if he
was willing to participate and help me
really great now you know work out the
scene and uh he politely declined oh so
basically smart guy yeah
once again as uh a serious actress i had
to
mime
the rectal exam
in front of tony i'm used to seeing i'm
used to seeing mimes walk against the
wind
be in a box that's a level of mime i
don't care to participate in i think